let's review i know i keep doing this
uh and maybe you get a little bit sick
of it however i find it helpful because
these these four are really crucial for
this topic they're kind of at the center
of
what what are decision support systems
okay it's this big flowery term but what
are they referring to
concretely so last week and actually the
term before that as well
our first kind our most basic kind of
decision support system was
a spreadsheet thank you
database that's um that's totally fine
because that is after all what a
spreadsheet is
um i think i said spreadsheet because
it's faster
and simpler and also people like oh yeah
especially i've seen them i know how to
work with them
now we moved on to the next client
uh we're moving on to the next kind
today but do you remember what they are
what do we call them relational
databases right
so as opposed to flat file
in a relational database
well what makes a relational database
different from a
flat file database spreadsheet
what's the distinguishing characteristic
they have a lot of spreadsheets and they
relate to each other okay good right so
this
is basically a whole bunch of these
with connections between the kind of
data that you've got okay
so relational databases in in a very
real way i'll release
our spreadsheets on steroids okay now
even though we're not going to look at
them today just very quickly so you
remember one of the
two more complicated types do you
remember what they were called
expert systems
and the very last one was modeled on the
human brain
so it's called an artificial neural
network we're going to spend plenty of
time looking at those two they're a lot
of fun
so relational databases is where we're
at today
okay now in order to explain well why
why look at these kind of things i want
to
go back to last week and you may even
like to open up the uh
basic simple spreadsheet decision
support system that you built
okay just to jog your memory my question
is
in the process of constructing that
decision support system okay
what kind of challenges did you
experience what kind of things were
difficult
what what was frustrating what kind of
limitations did you have
when you were making your decision
support system anyone want to start us
off
okay so let's get let's get to this uh
we're looking at
these and we'll look at the shortcomings
of spreadsheets right
as a uh as a decision support system
so oklahoma just said sorry iklavi just
said increasing complexity
now i think that's right i think that's
probably the big one but i want to go
after it a little more because that's
quite vague
right and in fact not only is it vague
but i just told you
i defined these four right as getting
increasingly
complex right so complexity is not
necessarily a bad thing
so in what way is the spreadsheets
the complexity of a spreadsheet and how
it gets more and more complex
why is that a shortcoming why is that a
problem
maybe i should ask i ask you all to do
different things with your spreadsheet
right
what kinds of scenarios and decisions
did you
take for your spreadsheet to help people
make decisions on
on the back what did you guys do
jack
yeah more specifically about what what
kind of decisions was your spreadsheet
helping people to make
okay healthy decisions a little more
specific helping about what like is it
about yeah tell me tell me more details
okay so that's what we covered that's
what i covered on the board what did you
do that was different
your lack of an answer is very
reassuring not
go finish your homework someone else who
actually did it
where did you go further from the
spreadsheet that you had
advice okay what kind of advice
okay good who else went in that
direction advice yeah all right sammy
what kind of advice did your spreadsheet
like what kind of options did you have
um
and had three different options okay
yeah so fat had a cd helper
yeah that's really neat yeah
average had uh maintain a healthy weight
yep and our thing had keeper balance
diet
okay sure all right so basically
or whatever class of kind of uh weight
level you were
right it gave you a recommendation after
that did anyone do anything drastically
different
from that yeah
good okay so if you took your
spreadsheet right and we had only a
handful of columns if you added some
more
like say waist size that's helpful right
so then you can make a further
recommendation
based on not just weight and height
right and age
but okay what are your proportions like
what recommendations did you make just
out of curiosity
uh that you're me like some people are
heavy but they might just be muscle
yep in that case they you're not fat
yeah good
good you're good so all right good now
you're getting at the fact that we've
got all these recommendations but
as you were producing your formulas
right you know it wasn't easy was it it
was very easy to make a very small error
and your whole spreadsheet just kind of
explodes uh and even if you haven't made
any errors
it was complex to try and put in any
kind of you know
for example samuel's one right you
basically had one recommendation per
level
well what if you're you've got average
people average weight right
well they don't they shouldn't all
really get one recommendation right
there's average people and that's a
really broad spectrum
uh you would want to have like four or
five or 40 or 50 different kinds of
recommendations
based on what kind of average person you
are
okay so when we say increasing
complexity here's the real problem
okay when you want to make increasingly
complex recommendations
okay so when your recommendations are
more detailed
when that goes up a little bit okay say
for instance instead of you know
one recommendation per body type okay
suppose you want to double that
and have two recommendations per body
type based on some other factor like say
waist size okay as the recommendations
detail goes up
the complexity of the whole system goes
up
disproportionately it becomes a lot more
complicated
okay uh if you want to think about it
like this
we were talking about one of the other
examples of decision support systems
was ibm's computer to play chess okay
ibm's computer to play chess now
when you want to make it better more
detailed
playing the game okay being able to read
more steps ahead
the complexity of the situation gets
dramatically worse as you just add the
ability to read one step ahead
or two steps ahead or three steps ahead
just adding a little bit more detail
makes the system much much worse okay so
it's not like
for instance you want to buy um
one donut it costs you a dollar and you
want to buy two donuts it costs you two
dollars and three donuts
three dollars okay in that case as you
increase what you're trying to do
the cost increases at the same rate okay
so this would be like you buy one donut
cost your dollar you buy two
two notes cost you ten dollars and then
three donuts cost you a hundred dollars
you're like for real
i don't wanna buy donuts anymore right
um of course that system doesn't make
sense because actually economically we
do things in reverse we reward people
for doing you know for buying larger
amounts but in this situation
right the system punishes you for trying
to do more
the cost increases um not
proportionately
to how much you're trying to do okay
what kind of decision you're trying to
handle
were there any other shortcomings that
you found with working with spreadsheets
ah okay right so one of the main
limitations maybe you didn't really
sense it because the data we had was
quite neat right
but all of the calculations we were
doing were just simple numerical ones
right
that's all you could really do you're
like is this value greater than this
or is this equal to this they're all
very very straightforward
simple okay so the calculations are all
numerical based
now of course things are gonna all boil
down to numerical
right but if we're say doing processing
with an image which again is
numbers at the very basic level okay
especially can't handle that kind of
thing
images even though it's numbers right
because it's a
higher data type it's not able to deal
with that kind of thing okay
question i'll give you one more okay
which is that it's similar to this first
one okay this is about the detail the
recommendations
i want to make one uh a highlighter
shortcoming to do with what kind of data
you have and how much
how much you've got now as um
the quantity of data you have increases
okay you run up against some problems
okay because if you remember
if you want to open excel back up now if
you haven't already got it
if you've got some numbers
okay let me make this a bit bigger i'm
sorry
okay now i've just got three fields here
okay which is
pretty similar to what you guys had last
week now if i want to
put these together in some kind of
calculation okay what does it look like
will you say something like this
uh this multiplied by this
plus uh this squared
okay and out will pop some number in a
second okay
the problem with this though is that
when you look over here
you're trying to understand what does
this thing do you're like b1 a1
what are any of those okay it's all very
abstract right
now why does it do that well excel is no
other way to describe what these are
okay because the structure of it is very
simple this doesn't actually
these fields don't have names they're
just column a and column b and column c
okay so as the amount of data increases
can you imagine if we didn't have three
fields
if you had say 30 fields what would this
thing look like it would be a disaster
no human could read it
okay uh at least not without the
university or something like that or
just sitting down
and looking and getting a piece of paper
and drawing although to try and work out
what each of these referred to
okay so here's the problem i'm trying to
draw out
when you have increasing amounts of data
how much data do you have
okay the spreadsheet becomes
increasingly incapable
of describing those pieces of data in
meaningful ways
okay because just like i don't know what
it is it's just every column is all the
same to me
okay and that brings us to relational
databases
okay so what differences
does a relational database have that
helps it
to deal with these problems how does it
deal with these problems
well for starters we know that databases
can handle a whole lot more kinds of
data
than just numerical data right we looked
at them before for instance
you can put in text you can do
operations on that you can put in binary
large objects it can do operations on
that as well
on this last point here think about how
you get data out of a database do you
remember we learned a whole language to
do with it
in that topic what was it called do you
remember sql now
sql structured query language it's not
easy to read either not as
easy as english right but it's
definitely easier to read than this
gobbledygook right it's actually in
words
okay it does involve some operations and
that kind of thing but
instead of b1a1c1 it'll say things like
student.name
okay because you can actually refer to
things by language human language
based on the names that you yourself
give them right so as the amount of data
increases
you don't get the same problem that you
have in a spreadsheet and lastly
as increase as complexity increases okay
we get all these different kinds of
operations that we can
uh insert into a database then it can
return something far more meaningful
and it's not as much of a mess to put in
if statements inside
if statements inside if statements
inside other functions which are really
really gross
to deal with okay